good morning i'm captain nick farisi of
the las vegas metropolitan police
department and i'm here to provide you
preliminary details of an
officer-involved shooting that occurred
today january 10 2022
this is the second officer-involved
shooting for the las vegas metropolitan
police department for 2022.
at 5 00 a.m this morning our special
weapons and tactics team was executing a
search warrant in the 3000 block of
nellis boulevard
while they were serving that search
warrant there was an exchange of gunfire
between the suspect and officers
two of our officers were struck as well
as the suspect the suspect was
pronounced deceased at scene
both of our officers were transported to
a hospital where they're currently being
treated for their injuries
these are preliminary details as i know
them right now
uh the sheriff or his designee will
provide further details within the next
72 hours in a more detailed briefing i
can take a few questions right now how
are the officers
right now the officers are being treated
for their injuries but they're uh stable
at this time so what was the search for
uh the search warrant was follow-up uh
investigation for a homicide that
occurred in november of 2021. was the
suspect killed this
morning in that homicide uh it's
preliminary details right now i i can't
confirm where to buy that we're still
investigating that right now sir you
expect the officers to survive yes the
officers are are expected to survive
during this
thank you guys